[Музика]
привіт усім, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звати Наталія Лашкар, давайте
почнемо сьогодні, ми продовжуємо розмову про
освіту та школу, тож давайте почнемо, і
я хотів би переглянути деякі прикметники, які
говорять про вчителів, тож давайте
почнемо  у грі це буде
гра у відгадки,
тож ви подивіться на моє обличчя, я збираюся
вимовити слово, але ви не почуєте
жодних звуків, тому вам потрібно вгадати, яке
слово я вимовляю
без звуку.  ще раз
українською для тебе так Прабхаваті логотип
я коли-небудь переконаюся, що це вуко він миє голландку
її тата поцілунок la ilaha
вода
давайте спробуємо сказати перше слово ходімо
ще раз чи
можете ви вгадати ще раз  ви
це цікаво, це була лише спроба
для вас, а тепер давайте з прикметниками, які
говорять про вчителів, тому перше
слово і ще раз слово
дивовижне і я хотів би поставити картку
жовта картка йде до слова дивовижно ми
пам'ятаємо  цей жовтий дивовижний так
num  бер два і ще один раз чи можете ви
вгадати слово красивий
добре зроблено красивий це буде
блакитний і жовтий дивовижний і синій
красивий добре зроблено давайте з
наступним словом
готове ще раз і ще одне
слово творче давайте
творчо  буде помаранчевим, давайте позначимо
його тут, так що синій ви пам'ятаєте
красивий і помаранчевий
креативний і жовтий дивовижний фантастичний у нас
є ще два слова, тож давайте ще
раз і ще одне, чи можете ви сказати слово, що
це добре
буде зелений, так жовтий - це дивовижний помаранчевий
креатив, що зелений добрий і блакитний
прекрасний фантастичний, і останні слова
давайте ще раз і ще одне, чи можете
ви вгадати слово це розумний, тому
воно буде фіолетовим розумним, і
давайте переглянемо п'ять слів
жовтий номер один дивовижний, тоді
красивий помаранчевий креативний зелений
добрий і фіолетовий – розумний Браво
всі ці функції дістаються вчителю,
ми збираємося описати вчителя
таким чином, і давайте '  послухайте
ще раз інтерв'ю з Реною та зосередьтесь
на граматиці, тому ми збираємося обговорити
деякі речення, які вона використовує у своїй
промові, тож давайте послухаємо ще раз
привіт, Рена, як справи, привіт Наталі,
я чудово, дякую, як справи  Я
фантастичний, дуже дякую, тому не могли
б ви представитися,
звичайно, мене звати Дорін Алу Кафка. Я
живу в Києві, Україна, я
вчитель, тренер-викладач, я навчаю дітей та
дорослих онлайн та віч-на-віч, а
також допомагаю людям  готуйся до іспитів
фантастично, як довго ти працюєш
вчителем англійської мови я
працюю вчителем з 2012 року, тому
я викладаю англійську мову вісім років
добре де ти почав працювати, я
спочатку в якому місці була державна школа  у
Києві там я працював переважно з
учнями початкових класів, це було дійсно чудово
, це цікаво, а як щодо вашого
останнього місця роботи я працював у великій
компанії, де я допомагав співробітникам
покращувати свою англійську Англійська мова
для них дуже важлива, оскільки th  вони беруть участь у
міжнародних зустрічах і конференціях,
де вони повинні спілкуватися
англійською мовою. Я бачу, що це чудово, і чому
ви вирішили стати вчителем
англійської, насправді я вирішив стати
вчителем, тому що це була моя дитяча
мрія з самого раннього віку.  хотілося мати
зошити з дошками і,
звичайно, студенти, коли я був дитиною,
я навчав своїх батьків своїх плюшевих ведмедиків
і своїх друзів, але в 2012 році я почав
вчити справжніх студентів, я переконаний,
що викладання - це робота мрії, і це
надзвичайно корисно, фантастично
твій професійний розвиток ти
продовжуєш навчатися, звичайно,
професійний розвиток дуже
важливий для кожного вчителя, якщо ми не
розвиваємось і не дізнаємося чогось нового, ми відчуваємо себе
дуже пригніченими. Я регулярно їжджу на
конференції, а також виступаю на
конференціях, також багато читаю та дивлюся
вебінари Мені подобається пізнавати нове та
ділитися своїми знаннями з іншими
фантастично, чому, на вашу думку, ми повинні
обрати вас на цю посаду  ion добре, мої
учні кажуть, що
я хороший учитель і що разом зі мною вони
досягають своїх навчальних цілей, а також я
вважаю, що я творча людина, а це
означає, що мої учні ніколи не нудьгують,
я також пунктуальний і відповідальний,
головне, я знаю, як  щоб допомогти студентам
зі складною граматикою та лексикою, щоб
вони розуміли та використовували їх, і, звичайно,
у моєму класі багато роботи з вимовою,
що дуже важливо,
фантастично,
тому останнє питання на сьогодні, яким
ви бачите себе через п’ять років, це
дуже  важко відповісти на запитання. Я
не впевнений, чи зможу я так багато планувати наперед.
Сподіваюся, що я й надалі допомагатиму
студентам удосконалювати свою англійську, також я думаю,
що за п'ять років я
напишу корисну книгу для вчителів, яка
стане відомою  день я бачу найкращу
фразу добре я думаю, що у мене немає
запитань, можливо, у вас є якісь
запитання до мене так, якщо ви не проти,
я хотів би поставити вам одне запитання добре,
який графік роботи вашої
школи  l у нас уроки в понеділок, п’ятницю
з 10 до 15.00.
вас це влаштовує о так, я абсолютно в
порядку, що
мені подобається більше працювати вранці та
вдень я добре бачу іноді у нас
є додаткові заходи, як-от
вечірні заходи, але це не це справжній
пацієнт, це не наш звичайний  добре,
дуже дякую, ми зв'яжемося з вами,
коли будемо готові рішення,
дякую, я буду чекати від вас,
дякую, добре,
тепер давайте обговоримо ваші речення, щоб, коли
ви бачите, це речення, які я
хотів би, щоб ви  зосередимося на сьогодні, давайте
почнемо з першої, яку я навчаю дітям
і дорослим онлайн та віч-на-віч, а
також вони допомагають людям підготуватися до
іспитів, тому це речення
складається з двох частин, які я навчаю дітей та
дорослих онлайн та віч-на-віч та  вони
також допомагають людям підготуватися до іспитів,
скажімо, я б хотів, щоб ви визначили час
, це теперішнє минуле чи майбутнє.
напружений ло  добре, у реченні я
навчаю дітей Браво,
так що це підмет плюс дієслово і це
присутній просто подивіться на другу
частину я також допомагаю людям у нас є
підмет я і дієслово допомагати добре,
давайте спробуємо з третьою особою однини,
якщо я скажу  не я, а вона, наприклад,
dureena,
тому Марина вчить молодець, ми не говоримо
навчати, ми говоримо вчителі, тому я можу
додати сюди плюс e як закінчення для третьої
особи однини дозвольте співвідношенням або тягарем e,
чи така музика в
Китаї така  ще раз я навчаю дітей, але
Марина навчає дітей молодці, чи
можете ви сказати про себе добре,
наприклад, я йду до школи
викладаю англійську вісім років,
це дуже гарне речення, наприклад, я
працюю вчителем чотирнадцять
років, і ви можете сказати, що я
вивчаю англійську протягом п’яти років,
наприклад, 11 років
або сім років, це залежить від вас
Звичайно, це Present Perfect
Continue, ми почали
щось робити в минулому, і ми все ще продовжуємо
це робити, тому давайте
підсумуємо, як переробити речення в
Present Perfect Continue,
добре, тепер давайте подивимося на
речення, яке я був  working I є
підметом, тоді ми маємо допоміжне дієслово half
in present, у нас також є форма для
cert person однини we don't set ending
es or else we don't say half we say has
so have або has плюс головне дієслово the
Present Perfect частина, тож формула для
Present Perfect становить половину або має плюс
дієслово у формі множини, тому нам потрібно використати
його be in і тоді ми, нарешті, маємо
дієслово із закінченням ing, тож давайте знову розглянемо
підмет, однак має plus be plus
дієслово на форумі, тож давайте подивимося
на речення I have been working as a
teacher or I have been learn English,
так що, як ви бачите, I have been, це те саме,
але різниця полягає в
дієслові work or learn давайте подивимося на мій
приклад ще раз  я  я вчив
англійську або я вивчав грецьку
протягом останніх місяців,
давайте подивимося на це речення ще раз чотири
слова, наприклад, з 2012 року і протягом восьми
років,
тож давайте подивимося на час підйому time
climb ми маємо пункт, який правильний 2012,
але сьогодні який рік  сьогодні ми маємо
2020 рік, скажімо, що арена працює
вчителем з 2012 року вона почала в 2012 році
і викладає англійську мову
бум вісім років, тож двадцять
двадцять дванадцять це вісім років, а у
нас період вісім років двадцять дванадцять
є  відправною точкою ми говоримо гріхи або протягом
восьми років добре, тому ви скажемо ще раз,
і ми починаємо з мого особистого прикладу
я працюю вчителем з
2006 року, тому я викладаю англійську мову
чотирнадцять років,
ви можете сказати про себе, наприклад,
я  вивчаю англійську мову з 2008 року, тому
я вивчаю її 12 років
, скажімо, з Реною вона
працює вчителем, і вона
викладає, пам'ятайте, ми кажемо, що
співає від третьої особи  ular давайте перейдемо до наступного
речення я працював у великій компанії,
де я допомагаю співробітникам покращувати свою
англійську мову, скажімо, я працював і я допомагав, що
це, це не теперішній час.
тож
давайте підсумуємо, як ми формуємо речення
в минулому простому
давайте подивимося я працював, скажімо, предмет плюс у
нас є дієслово із закінченням IDI або друга
форма дієслова say, якщо це звичайне
дієслово, як work, і допоможіть нам просто додати
закінчення edy
якщо дієслово неправильне, ми змінюємо його,
наприклад, навчати, давайте спробуємо
на прикладі я працював у великій компанії,
де я допомагав співробітникам, скажімо про
Dureena, сумна особа однини, вона працювала
у великій компанії, і вона допомогла йому,
будь ласка, є зміни, ні  не
змінюється ми використовуємо те саме okay, давайте
скажемо інше речення зі
звичайними дієсловами, наприклад, вона викладала
у великій компанії, і вона сказала йому, будь ласка,
добре, молодець, давайте підемо до наступного
, коли я був дитиною  Раніше я навчав
своїх батьків своїх плюшевих ведмедиків і друзів,
але в 2012 році я почав навчати справжніх
студентів, тому почнемо з
кінця речення. Я почав вчити справжніх
студентів.
Я почав так, це минуле просто.
дієслово
але давайте подивимося на
початок речення, коли я був дитиною,
я навчав, це дуже гарна фраза,
давайте запишемо її тут, а
також ми також говоримо з минулими подіями, які
я навчав, якщо я зупинився  роблячи це,
наприклад,
Дюріна каже у своєму реченні, що
колись навчала своїх плюшевих ведмедиків своїх
друзів і батьків, але в 2012 році
вона заговорила, вона почала навчати справжніх
студентів, тому дію було зупинено, ви
можете сказати, що раніше я вивчала
італійську мову, але я припинила, тому що я  більше не
використовую я можу сказати про себе. Раніше
я вивчав німецьку мову, але зараз я цього не роблю,
я зупинився добре, давайте йти далі, у нас буде
більше речень, якщо ми не розвиваємось і не
вивчаємо щось нове, ми відчуваємо себе дуже
пригніченими, то що  про це с  укажіть,
що це за час або що
це за речення. Ключове слово для
вас: якщо так, це умовне слово, тому ми маємо
нульовий умовний умовний номер один
і два,
який це умовний спосіб, добре, якщо
ми подивимося на речення, якщо ми  не
розвивайте це щось на кшталт того, що ми говоримо
про майбутнє Джек Шерман стрілки
vivimos природа більше вибору Нова
добре, тому якщо ми не розвиваємось, ми відчуваємо себе дуже
пригніченими,
це нуль умовних умов, і давайте
переглянемо формулу для нульових умов, у
нас є дві частини  речення, які я
збираюся написати тут, якщо плюс подивіться на
речення не розвиваються це присутнє
просте теперішнє просте і в другій
частині подивіться ми відчуваємо себе дуже пригніченими ми також
маємо теперішнє просте сказати якщо ми не
розвиваємось і не робимо щось нове  ми відчуваємо себе
дуже пригніченими, якщо ми не йдемо на прогулянку,
ми відчуваємо себе дуже втомленими або якщо ми не вивчаємо
англійську мову, ми не збираємося схвалювати
це також можливо, давайте рухатися далі я люблю
вчитися новому та ділитися своїми
знаннями з іншими  s ви можете сказати
Наталія, я люблю це
теперішній простий час так,
але якщо говорити про граматику,
це дуже цікаве речення, і багато
людей роблять помилки,
чому, тому що після слова love або like
what,
використовуючи форму Bravo ing, давайте запишемо це
і для цього я виберу рожевий
колір, це мій улюблений, так що люблю або
як ми використовуємо дієслово з формою ing.
ці знання
з іншими, давайте перейдемо ще на одне
речення Я сподіваюся, що я буду продовжувати допомагати
студентам покращувати свою англійську Я сподіваюся,
так, за допомогою пристрою, що я буду продовжувати допомагати
, продовжуватиму допомагати what's this which kind
of time is this it's not the present
it's not the  past Bravo this is the
future
so future simple давайте переглянемо,
як ми формуємо речення в future
simple let's go Я буду продовжувати допомагати, тому
ми маємо тему плюс will, а потім
дієслово
lets look I will continue helping is t  він
наступне слово, тому я буду продовжувати допомагати
студентам, я буду продовжувати, я буду читати
цю книгу тема will + дієслово let's
change it into dureena,
так що арена буде продовжувати допомагати студентам
чи це змінюється,
щоб не змінювати тему + will +
дієслово it's the  однаково для всіх давайте йдемо, у
нас є останнє речення. Також я думаю,
що через п'ять років я
напишу корисну книгу для вчителів, яка
колись стане відомою, тож давайте
почнемо з кінця речення, яке
одного дня стане відомим, яке стосується
до книги напишіть корисну книгу для
вчителів, щоб ми могли замінити це
слово на книгу, щоб книга стала
відомою давайте подивимося на приклад
майбутнього простого предмета клас will + дієслово
книга стане таким чином це приклад для
вас і давайте  почніть з основної частини, я
думаю, що через п'ять років я
напишу це дуже цікаву
частину, яку я напишу, ви бачите,
слово написали це означає, що
це ідеальна форма, але ми також маємо бажання, так
що  s - майбутній досконалий час, це означає,
що до 2025 року через п'ять років
справа Дуріна
закінчить у своїй книзі, вона
буде готова до того часу, коли вона завершить
цю дію до того часу, коли дія
буде закінчена  і ми можемо сказати, що я
написав корисну книгу,
тому книга буде закінчена, давайте
переглянемо, як ми складаємо речення в
майбутніх досконалих термінах, щоб у нас був I, який
є предметом плюс буде з майбутнього,
тепер нам потрібно мати ідеальну форму, тому  у
нас є допоміжне, а потім дієслово,
і ми використовуємо сумну форму для дієслова, тому
ми маємо sub J plus will Plus have
plus дієслово в третій формі, тож давайте подивимося
на приклад, який я написав, давайте
змінимо його на dureena  арена
буде написано чи це зміниться зараз це
не так, як у
майбутньому просто вона буде або я буду це
не має значення
і давайте спробуємо інший приклад давайте
поговоримо про себе наприклад я сподіваюся,
що в  п'ять років, які я збираюся
закінчити  моя грецька мова, тому я можу сказати, що через п'ять років
я вивчу грецьку мову не повністю, але
я досягну рівня, вибачте,
давайте підсумуємо у нас є речення з
простим теперішнім, чи можете ви швидко навести мені
приклад так я навчаю дітей Браво
давайте підсумуємо минулий простий час чи можете
ви  знайти приклад я працював у великій
компанії я почав викладати і я
тримав співробітників давайте переглянемо теперішнє
ідеальне безперервно я працюю
вчителем або я викладаю
добре, що щодо колишньої форми
я навчав своїх ведмедиків  і мої
батьки та мої друзі фантастичні, а як
щодо майбутнього простого я буду продовжувати
допомагати учням, інакше книга стане
відомою одного дня, і майбутнє ідеальне
добре, я написав корисну книгу,
фантастику та два останні правила,
тож давайте переглянемо речення if  ми
не розвиваємось і не вчимося чогось нового, ми
відчуваємо депресію, і що ми використовуємо з
любов'ю і як Bravo дієслово з
формою ing I love learn Я люблю читати я
люблю вивчати англійську і, нарешті,  давайте
переглянемо прикметники який був
фіолетовий колір розумний Браво і зелений
один вид помаранчевий креативний синій красивий
і жовтий дивовижний Я сподіваюся, що у вас
був чудовий урок зі мною,
тож на сьогодні все, що я чую, як дзвонить дзвінок, а
це означає, що нам потрібно  стоп,
дуже дякую, що приєднався до мене сьогодні, і
наступного разу вони побачать вас, до побачення,
[Музика].